[Applaus]
[Musik]
jahrzehntelang war die warnung vor dem
peak oil das also schon bald das erdöl
ausgeht eine regelmäßig wiederkehrende
vorhersage die immer und immer wieder
alarmistische schlagzeilen und auch
kontroversen er vor ich sogar in den
schulen wollte sie den kindern immer
wieder eingetrichtert und vielleicht
auch du dich noch trank gut früher
standen sind weniger nutzbare energie
quellen zur verfügung als heute die
ganze sache hat nur einen haken aldi
höherer prognosen traten nie ein
und auch wenn der weltuntergang immer
wieder auf morgen verschoben werden
musste war den angst machen eines klar
eines tages wurde das lang ersehnte ende
des öls ganz bestimmt kommen
die welt wird in zehn jahren kein öl
mehr haben us bureau of mines im jahr
die welt wird in 13 jahren kein öl mehr
haben us department of veterans 1930 und
1950 die welt dort bis 1990 kein öl und
keine anderen fossilen brennstoffe mehr
haben
paul ehrlich die grenzen des wachstums
im jahr 1972
die welt wird 2030 kein öl mehr haben
und 2050 keine anderen fossilen
brennstoffe paul ehrlich wie jahren will
er mit im jahr 2002 wie du sehen kannst
haben all diese hoch angesehenen
experten vor allem eines gemein sie
lagen total daneben damit waren sie
eigentlich die perfekten contra
indikatoren denn das einzige worauf man
sich verlassen konnte war dass das
genaue gegenteil ihrer vorhersagen
eintrat denn was all diese
wissenschaftler komischerweise nie in
betracht gezogen haben war der
technische fortschritt und wir sprechen
hier war nicht nur über erdöl die angst
vor dem versiegen aller möglichen
reichlich vorhandenen energiequellen ist
noch immer ein riesen hit unter
journalisten analysten und experten
aller art eines hat sich jedoch geändert
früher war das hauptargument erst mache
das ist die vorräte ausgehen und dann
alle verhungern oder erfrieren müssen
diese begründung hat sich scheinbar
ausgelutscht denn heute dreht sich alles
nur noch ums klima den untergang des
planeten und deswegen teilen sie nach
wie vor die ganze welt mit aller macht
in eine zukunft ohne fossile brennstoffe
die ganze welt nein nicht die ganze welt
ähnlich den berühmten gallischen
dörfchen gibt es ein land das von
unnachgiebigen samurai bevölkert wird
die allen widrigkeiten zum trotz
widerstand leisten
du glaubst du nicht nun in den letzten
jahren stellte sich japan mit zähigkeit
gegen den globalen trend es hat sein
verbrauch an fossilen brennstoffen nicht
nur nicht reduziert es hat ihn sogar
erhöht
[Applaus]
das jahr 2011 war so etwas wie ein
wendepunkt für japan das erdbeben und
der darauffolgende tsunami mit seinen
verheerenden auswirkungen auf das
atomkraftwerk in fukushima verändert den
umgang des landes mit energie waren die
japaner bis zu diesem zeitpunkt große
atomkraft fest verflüssigt alles anders
sie wollten sich nach alternativen
umsehen
der vorfall in fukushima führte dazu
dass viele der atomreaktoren des landes
abgeschaltet wurden eine situation die
bis heute anhält aber der strom musste
trotzdem ja irgendwo herkommen
tja und woher nehmen und nicht stehlen
erneuerbare energien reichten einfach
nicht aus
daher nutzte japan zunächst erdöl und
vor allem gas sehr viel darf
im jahr 2016 stieg die nutzung fossiler
primärenergieträger bereits auf mehr als
90 prozent des japanischen
gesamtverbrauchs in einem land mit so
wenig nutzbaren natürlichen ressourcen
wie japan führte dies dazu dass mehr als
80 prozent des energiebedarfs durch
importe gedeckt werden mussten
japan ist damit eines der am stärksten
energie gegen länder der welt nun und
das ließ in tokio natürlich alle
alarmglocken schrillen denn es ging bei
der ganzen geschichte nicht nur um
umweltpolitik sondern vor allem um ein
strategisches wirtschaftliches und
politisches problem für ein land wie
japan das bei der versorgung mit
fossilen brennstoffen vollständig vom
ausland abhängig ist und alles auch noch
per schiff heranschaffen muss ist ein
solches nadelöhr ein großes risiko für
die nationale sicherheit besonders in
einer zeit in der sie jean ping die
ganze region auf den kopf stellt
deswegen setzten japanische politiker
jahrelang auf kernenergie als besten weg
um in energiefragen autonom zu sein nach
fukushima verlor atomkraft jedoch den
rückhalt in der bevölkerung
deswegen haben sich die japaner auf die
entwicklung erneuerbarer energien
gestürzt als gäbe es kein morgen
vor allem auf die solarenergie aber
natürlich lässt sich die atomstrom nicht
von heute auf morgen durch die ersetzt
was also haben sich die japaner
einfallen lassen hatten sie irgendwelche
innovativen ideen
nun ihre strategie klingt auf den ersten
blick sagen wir mal überraschend sie
wollen eines der größten förderländer
für erdgas werden
dabei steht ihnen nur ein klitzekleines
problem im weg sie haben kein erdgas
zumindest nicht jenes das wir als
konventionelles erdgas kennen und genau
an diesem punkt wird es zeit eines der
größten geopolitischen asse in japans
ärmel zu enthüllen methanhydrat hast du
schon mal was man die substanz gehört
nun passt gut auf du wirst ganz schön
überrascht sein wo es hier eigentlich
geht und was genau japan damit vorhat
[Musik]
brennbares eis
vielleicht hast du schon mal ausgesehen
dass sich entzündet wenn man eine
flammende anhält
dabei handelt es sich natürlich nicht
ungewöhnliches sondern um methan eis in
diesen bildern wassermoleküle kleine
käfige in denen dann methan moleküle
eingeschlossen sind wenn die metall
molekülen aus dem wasser giftigen
befreit werden
bilden sie das altbekannte erdgas und
das kann dann brennen so jetzt kommt
aber der clou mit antrat ist nicht nur
ein nettes gimmick auf partys oder
ähnlich wie unterricht sondern es kommt
auf unserem planeten in gigantischen
mengen vor
speziell unter dem meeresboden und
aufgepasst denn gerade seine lage macht
es zu einem der begehrtesten aber
gleichzeitig auch zu einem der
umstrittensten rohstoffen
denn zum einen befinden sich auf den
meeresboden einzigartige und
empfindliche ökosysteme und zum anderen
ist der abbau von rohstoffen aus der
tiefe ein extrem riskantes unterfangen
erinnerst du dich noch an die
apokalyptische katastrophe der deepwater
horizon im golf von mexiko nun es wird
vermutet dass bei der explosion dieser
bottler formel gerade methanhydrat eine
entscheidende rolle gespielt hat
trotzdem dieser rohstoff ist so
verlockend dass ein paar katastrophen
seine ausbeutung nicht aufhalten werden
denn um die bedeutung dieser ressource
zu verstehen müssen wir über ihr
außerordentliches potential reden
welches nicht wahrscheinlich ziemlich
umhauen wird
[Musik]
warum nur methanhydrat ist die am
häufigsten vorkommende kohlenstoff
quelle auf der erde
es macht schätzungsweise ein drittel des
gesamten kunststoffs auf den planeten
aus mehr als alle anderen fossilen
energiequellen zusammengenommen wegen
nichts geringerem als methanhydrat den
china seine maritimen ansprüche im
südchinesischen meer auf biegen und
brechen aus der sprechen jedoch von
einer chemischen substanz die sehr
instabil hoch entzündlich und besonders
empfindlich gegenüber druck und
temperatur ist aufgrund dieser
eigenschaften ist seine gewinnung bei
weitem nicht so einfach wie
traditioneller bergbau und warum
sprechen wir in bezug auf methanhydrat
eigentlich gerade über japan nun schau
dir mal diese weltkarte an jeder der
grund punkte ist ein bekanntes vorkommen
von methanhydrat
[Musik]
wie du sehen kannst befindet sich die
höchste bekannte konzentration dieses
rohstoffs genau um japan die japanische
küstenlinie ist buchstäblich übersät mit
ablagerungen diese verbindung das liegt
vor allem am zusammenfluss der
tektonischen platten und den riesigen
sedimentablagerungen vor seiner küste
na bitte da haben die japaner wenigstens
einen vorteil im wohl am meisten
erdbeben gefährdeten gebiet dieses
planeten zu wohnen methanhydrat im
überfluss
[Musik]
um die eine vorstellung zu geben
die japanische regierung schätzt die
offshore lagerstätten in ihrem
hoheitsgebiet auf mindestens 7 billionen
kubikmeter
das könnte genug sein um japans gesamten
gasverbrauch für fast ein jahrhundert zu
decken
möglicherweise ist dies aber nur die
spitze des eisbergs und es könnte noch
viel mehr davon geben und genau aus
diesem grund gibt es wenig zweifel daran
dass die methanhydrat gewinnung die
energieversorgung für eine sehr sehr
lange zeit garantieren könnte
offensichtlich nicht nur in japan tja
wenn es dann nicht ein kleines problem
gebe man weiß einfach nicht gut genug
wie das erdgas aus dem methanhydrat
geschickt extrahiert und
weiterverarbeitet werden kann
nach dem aktuellen stand der technik bis
zwei möglichkeiten eine nennen wir sie
die konventionelle und die anderer dass
die uns die revolutionäre nennen jene
die japan zu entwickeln versucht der
traditionelle weg diesen rohstoff zu
fördern ist das bohren in den
meeresboden in einer tiefe von etwa 1000
metern unter der wasseroberfläche
die vorkommen befinden sich dann meist
noch mehrere hundert meter unter dem
meeresboden und die brutalen bedingungen
dort extrem hohen druck machen diese
bohrungen so komplex und teuer dass
diese option derzeit kommerziellen nicht
rentabel ist aber es gibt ja zum glück
noch den revolutionären weg an den japan
arbeitet unternehmen simo deckt und
mitsubishi shipbuilding entwickeln so
dass schiffe die in der lage sind
methanhydrat vorkommen in küstennähe
sicher zu fördern und das geht so man
sticht das reservoir nur an um darin für
eine druckentlastung zu sorgen die wärme
zur zersetzung des methanhydrat zu
methan wird dabei von der umgebenden
formation geliefert sodass es zu förder
schiff aufsteigen kann welches wiederum
auf andere hilfsstoffe zurückgreift es
an land zu transportieren
klingt einfach nicht wahr nun in
wahrheit ist es überhaupt nicht einfach
die förderung von methan aus
methanhydrat vorkommen er fordert
maßgeschneiderte bohrtechnologie denn
wenn es nicht richtig gemacht wird kann
es zu einer ganzen reihe von desaströsen
havarien kommen
wenn zum beispiel sand oder etwas
anderes durch das bohrloch in das
reservoir gelangt wird das amt antrat
darin und brauchbar aber das wäre nur
ein mittelschweres missgeschick im
schlimmsten fall kann es zu gewaltigen
explosionen kommen und es können auch
gewaltige mengen an methan in die
atmosphäre gelangen und methan ist ein
25 mal so starkes treibhausgas die co2
deswegen arbeitet japan an der
vervollkommnung dieses verfahrens das
ziel ist ist gas das und noch mehr gas
für japan zu fördern und zwar so billig
wie möglich aber wir dürfen hier ein
wichtiges detail nicht übersehen japan
strebt danach die führende macht bei der
wasserstoffproduktion zu werden und
wasserstoff eben genau auf sie jedem das
zu produzieren das aus methanhydrat
vorkommen gewundert und wie wir kürzlich
beweisen ein video über wasserstoff
berichtet haben dass sich die übrigens
in der beschreibung verlinken werde
können die auswirkungen enorm sein und
die gesamte globale energie wirtschaft
umkrempeln
aufgepasst
japans sprungbrett zur wasserstoff
economy
nur die wir im wasserstoff video erzählt
haben kann dieser kraftstoff auf
verschiedene arten hergestellt werden
die geschichte ist in aus kohle erdgas
und neuerdings auch mit erneuerbaren
energien herzustellen und darin liegt
der schlüssel sowie japans
energiestrategie der zukunft erdgas wird
aus methanhydrat extrahiert und daraus
dann der wasserstoff hergestellt damit
du dir eine vorstellung davon machen
kannst aus einem kubikmeter mit handrad
können etwa 160 kubikmeter methangas
gewonnen werden das dann auch in
wasserstoff umgewandelt werden kann auf
diese weise können länder mit großen
methanhydrat vorkommen wie japan sehr
schnell auf wasserstoff umsteigen und in
der sauberen sport unabhängige
treibstoff müssen daher sind
methanhydrat und wasserstoff die
tragenden säulen der japanischen
energiestrategie die regierung will den
wasserstoff verbraucht bis 2050 auf über
20 millionen tonnen pro jahr steigern
ein recht hohes ziel vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass die energieausbeute von
wasserstoff pro kilogramm dreimal so
hoch ist wie die von benzin
das aber nur erreicht werden kann wenn
die produktionskosten deutlich gesenkt
werden können daher sollen die kosten
für die wasserstoffproduktion wohl
zurzeit 100 auf 20 yen pro kubikmeter
sinken das heißt von 76 auf 5 10 euro
cent und dafür braucht das land
methanhydrat denn eine solche absenkung
der energiekosten würde die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der japanischen
wirtschaft in den himmel katapultieren
aber nicht nur das die herstellung von
wasserstoff aus den hydra wäre sauberer
als aus anderen quellen
damit handelt rat bei der verbrennung 30
prozent weniger kohlendioxid ausstößt
als kohle oder öl und erst du vielleicht
einwenden 30 prozent weniger co2 ist
schon gut die restlichen 70 prozent sind
aber kein pappenstiel
so wird das klima aber nicht gerettet ok
dann hatte ich jetzt mit dem test denn
es wird in japan auch an einer
gewinnungs methode von methan und rad
durch austausch des methans gegen
kohlenstoffdioxid geforscht
dabei wird also co2 in den eben
erwähnten wasser käfigen eingeschlossen
so das kohlenstoffdioxid rathaus
entsteht und dies ist wieder unter dem
meeresboden eingelagert wird die
gewinnung und energetische verwendung
des so bewundern mit tanz und damit
wasserstoffs wäre also weitgehend
klimaneutral
ja panik unterirdisches feuer eis als
quelle für sauber verbrennenden
wasserstoff das ist also die japanische
version der energiewende
auf diese weise könnte japan eine enorme
energie autonomie erreichen und nebenbei
den planeten retten
ok und wie sieht es mit der umsetzung
aus nur 2017 schaffte das land der
aufgehenden sonne in einem
experimentellen projekt 24 tage lang mit
allrad oder technische zwischenfälle zu
fördern und nicht nur das die regierung
glaubt dass in der lage sein wird
zwischen 2023 und 27 kommerzielle
methanhydrat projekte auf den weg zu
bringen
soweit zumindest ihr neuestes magic
energy kleine was meinst du denkst du
dass die wasserstoff aus methanhydrat
revolution die globale energie
wirtschaft umkrempeln kann wird sie gar
japan zur führenden energie macht des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts machen
eine energie macht die usa russland und
saudi arabien ablösen wird
oder denkst du dass sie aufgrund der
umweltrisiken auf keinen fall
durchgeführt werden sollte teilt eure
meinung bitte wir immer mit uns und auch
an anderen im kommentarbereich unter
diesem video
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat falls ja muss bitte ein
kleines like und teilt es auch mit euren
freunden und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren was gut und bis bald
[Musik]